على مسمعن من صرخات الموضعين شق الورد
القضاء الاوروبي طريقه الى قصر العدل
يوم جديد من الاستجوابات يخضع لها نواب
سابقون لحاكم مصرف لبنان ومديرون عمون
لمصاريف كانت شهده على تحويل مبالغ ضخمه
وصلت الى نصف مليار دولار اموال تعود
لرياض سلامه الحاكم الذي امنه اللبنانيون
على ارزاقهم فخسرها فيما تمكنا هو عبر
شركه يملكها شقيقه من تحويل الملايين الى
الخارج
ست سنوات
بحق اصحاب المصارف ولا مره استدعى صاحب
مصرف لها السبب ان احنا مع اي تحرك او
نشاط ممكن يؤدي للكشف عن مصيرنا خمسه
مصاريف
لائحه المطوله من الاسئله
في تلك المصارف وان لم تكن متورطه لكنها
كانت شاهده على عمليات تحويل التي جعلت من
سليم مشتبهان به في تهم تبيض اموال
اما القضاء اللبناني فلم يحرك ساكنا ولم
يتعاون مع القضاء الاوروبي في قضايا فساد
وقعت ضمن اراضيه للتاخذ الدول الاوروبيه
على عاتقها مهمه التوجه الى لبنان
واذا ابقى قضاء لبنان على دوره كمتفرج لن
يتمكن اللبنانيون من استرداد اموالهم
الموهوبه في حال وضعت الدول الاوروبيه
يدها على اموال سلامه
عن هدفين رئيسيه الهدف الاول الاستعداد
لهذه المرحله لاسترداد ما سيتم الاستيلاء
عليه والحجز عليه في هذه الدول الاوروبيه
والهدف الثاني استغلال ما يحصل الان في
حال اقدم المحقق الاوروبي على افاده
القضاء وبالتالي اصدار الادانات والاحكام
ان يستفيد القضاء اللبناني والسلطات
اللبنانيه من هذه الاحكام للتوسع في عمليه
التحقيق
[موسيقى]
اللبناني محكوم بالتدخلات السياسيه منذ
ثلاثين عاما ان عملوا الوفد الاوروبي
فسيبرهن ان لا احد فوق القانون
يعمل اللبنانيون ان يتخذوا القضاء
الاوروبي اجراءات عجزه عنها القضاء
اللبناني فالمواطنون بانتظار محاسبه من
اساء اليهم باي طريقه ممكنه غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت